good morning Hank it's Wednesday I want
to begin by thanking you for your
extraordinarily thoughtful and nuanced
video about Haiti and you also gave us a
real way to really help link in the
dooblydoo and I don't know how to
respond to your brilliance and your
compassion except by sharing with you
stupid questions that people ask Google
that's right Hank it's time for Google
autofill once again proves that people
are weird Hank today I'm gonna answer
the top ten questions people ask Google
beginning why does mine
why does my eye twitch I have great news
your eye doesn't twitch more on that in
a second why does my cat lick me okay
I'm gonna let you in on a little secret
cats
believe that all other organisms are
cats once you realize that a lot of cat
behavior begins to make sense so why
does your cat lick you because it thinks
it's grooming you so when your cat licks
you he's thinking I love you gigantic
hairless cat and to show you I will lick
you why does my urine smell probably
because you're dehydrated although it
could be because you have maple syrup
urine disease maple syrup urine disease
which by the way is completely real is a
rare disease with four main symptoms the
first is that your urine smells like
maple syrup the other three are coma
brain damage and death but hopefully you
just need to drink some water
why does my dog eat poop because he can
Hank so a couple years ago I was at the
doctor and he said you have a parasite
called Campylobacter and I said okay how
do you get that parasite and he said you
get it from eating feces and I was like
well I'm just gonna throw this out there
um just so you know I don't eat feces I
mostly you know foods and then that that
food turns into feces and then I just
let the feces go and he was like oh yeah
most people get it from being licked by
their dogs well it green what did you
get me Campylobacter anyway it turns out
that dogs eat poop mostly because
they're bored or stressed out so if your
dog is eating poop give em other stuff
to do why does my stomach hurt I'd look
into the possibility of Campylobacter
why does my eyelid twitch is what you
meant earlier when you asked about your
eye twitching it's probably because you
stare at screens all day long and
googling the problem is not helping why
does my cat bite me I think that's what
the Zen masters would call a question
wrongly put the question isn't why does
my cat bite me the question is when did
my cat become a vampire and what can I
do about it
and the answers are probably pretty
recently or else you'd already be dead
and nothing I'm sorry
make your peace with your friends and
with your enemy
because your time is short owner of
vampire cat why does my stomach growl
because your stomach has told your brain
to tell your stomach that you are hungry
and that leads to some muscle
contractions and releases of acids and
it's just global why does my dog lick
everything interestingly the same reason
your dog eats poop it's because you
spend all your time on the Internet and
none of your time with your dog so he or
she is bored and lastly why does my
computer keep freezing why are you being
so mean to your computer it's obviously
working well enough for you to Google
but to answer your question porn BOTS so
there you have it Hank 2:10 how does my
questions people ask Google the most I
have one for you how does my little blue
guy fall down every single time I make a
video Hank thanks again for reminding us
that the hardest problems are the ones
that most needs solving I'll see you on
Friday
dftba